could another duck dynasty star be  heading to dancing with the stars hey  you guys i'm katie krause and this is  trending on et now  john luke robertson would love to follow  in his younger sister's footsteps by  making his way to the ballroom on an  upcoming season of dancing with the  stars sadie robertson who is still in  the running for the mirror ball trophy  alongside her partner mark ballas is one  of this season's breakout stars  when john luke swung by e.t to spell  details about his upcoming wedding he  shared his dancing aspirations saying he  would absolutely be up for the challenge  i have some doubters but i think i could  do it i'd say i would so what do you  guys think about this idea should  another robertson keep the quack pack  alive next season or are you totally  against this idea let me know over on  twitter i'm katie underscore krauss and  of course keep checking back to et  online for all the latest entertainment  news